[Music]
foreign
Pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with the columnist Carl Malone
and Alison Morris who is a columnist for
the Belfast Telegraph with us from now
until just before midnight and welcome
to both of you
um lots to discuss not least to look
ahead to that mini budget tomorrow
um but the backdrop of this uh Carol is
as we read in the eye mortgage hikes and
recession
yeah the banker the bank of England are
suggesting that we're already in
recession in recession that they
actually said that today they put the
rates up from 1.75 to 2.25
um which is going to be this is going to
be a hell of a blow for people uh who
are on a variable rate mortgage I mean
this is a massive hike they're saying
it's going to be could be up to 50
pounds a month more for people on
trackers it's not going to affect the
people on fix rate mortgages yet but
that's that's going to hit them very
soon
um but the great news today of course is
the um the the
chancellor has said that he's going to
reverse the um their national insurance
tax hike and that means that nearly I
think there's about 920 000 businesses
are going to get a tax reduction of
about 10 000 pounds which is incredible
it was a 1.2 Rise
um that's now going to be reversed in
November I think and so it's it's you
know it's it's a it's a good and bad day
and all sorts of fun something the
budget is coming tomorrow we kind of
know what's in it we we know what's
coming and I think I may have to eat my
words about Liz trust I was saying that
she was weak and indecisive and making
lots of promises during the election
that she was never going to be able to
keep and she's going full Pelt now you
know with the the tax uh taxi you know
she's going to get rid of the National
Insurance increase she's going to get
rid of the corporation tax increase
she's going to lower taxes energy bills
freeze
um it's gonna be it's gonna be they're
calling it a mini budget but this is not
by any stretch of the imagination and
maybe budget this is a massive budget
and I said I saw a figure today that
said for every minute the chancellor
would be on his feet tomorrow will cost
two billion pounds of country children
so it's an awful lot of money
whether I mean that's that's absolutely
extraordinary isn't it um you say we
know what's in it um let's take a look
at the guardian
um again economy and recession as
quoting unveils his mini budget
um the bits we know are in it are the
bits that were promised I guess by Liz
trust during her many hustings and her
Manifesto efforts
um which is um as you said the National
Insurance uh rise which has gone from
November the 6th
um acts the planned increase in
corporation tax uh which was due to go
up from 19 25
and scrap the the cap on Bankers bonuses
which we heard I think last week did we
not as part of wider City deregulation
other elements of it though have been
reported but I guess not yet confirmed
Alison
um issues such as stamp Duty
um a fast track of a schedule 1p cut to
income tax and this slashing of vat from
20 to 15 across the board all reportedly
being considered we wait to see how far
Mr squatting will go with this idea of
of a sort of reversal in in text to
becoming a tax cutting government
um what's your best bet
well I do think that the government have
had because of the period of morning
they've had a longer planning period
than they would have had you know
they've had a number of days they've got
over a week now to put these plans in
place where obviously they sort of they
would have had to make these
announcements much quicker so I suppose
let's give them more preparation time a
lot of what's planned it will help
businesses as Carl said but there's also
the the plan to increase the potential
increase on people's mortgages of over
270 pounds in some cases a month if you
add that to the increase in the cost of
food and if you add that to the increase
in energy costs that's just going to
[ __ ] some homeowners and then we're
going to see a repeat of the previous
recession where people are just going to
have their homes repossessed because
they're just going to be unable to make
those payments the guardian is slightly
more skeptical of how these plans are
going to solve our current crisis than
some of the other papers which are
obviously welcoming those moves they
will help some but I don't see how much
of this is going to help those on the
sort of middle income and low-income
rules of the latter people who are
really really suffering already and
let's face it you know we haven't even
been anywhere near the cold spell we
haven't really seen the impact of those
huge increases in energy but people will
start feeling them as we go into October
and November and December that price cap
I think is one of the most important
things and the fact you know from a
purely selfish point of view we still
have no function and assembly no
Devolution in Northern Ireland a lot of
these issues are they going to be rolled
out across all of nations are we all
going to equally
um have access to any of the price Cuts
in terms of the mitigations for people
for energy and also those caps on Energy
prices because they're going to be
essential coming in to these winter
months are really fair for her you know
some people who are already struggling
are going to cope we would hope that
this government takes into consideration
not just how to help the very wealthy
and those in business keep afloat during
this crisis but also how to keep those
people who are struggling to either feed
and you know feed their children and
hate their homes at this time because
they are the people who need the help
instantly they didn't know yes and
certainly everyone's suggesting today
that the National Insurance cut helps
the better off and not those at the
lowest uh income levels
um but the fundamental Focus that we'll
hear tomorrow morning is growth Daily
Express is once celebrating that while
welcoming that and the suggestion that
quasi-quarting will announce the
creation of low tax low regulation
investment zones in his mini budget the
list of 38 of them you know Blackpool
Council Bedford Kent Lancashire you name
it um and the idea is to liberalize
planning rules in specified agreed sides
releasing land and accelerating
development the problem with this for
some people will be Carol
um that some of these projects will be
via watering down environmental
assessments and other regulations
um this is the idea as well as these
investment zones are speeding up around
100 major infrastructure projects so you
know I think this will will come with um
with with a strong critique
you know she has already sick the start
of the week when there was some of the
the budget was being leaked she has
already said she doesn't care if if what
she does is unpopular All She Wants To
Do Is grow the economy because she knows
we cannot survive we we we're not
sustainable as a country with the low
level of growth we have now so she she
has said she wants to do what works not
what is popular and and what makes her I
think you know it's kind of impressing
me in the sense that you know boris's
government and was flip-flopping all the
time if there was an unpopular policy
other was uproar over a policy it was
suddenly changed overnight she's she's
not gonna do that it was interesting
today I'll say here from the telegraph
said that she she is the person to to
deliver a brexit that actually works he
said you know she's going hell for
leather this is kind of what that did
back in 1998 with Nigel Lawson's budget
and she's going for that you know hell
for leather so she's not she knows she's
going to upset some people but her job
she is saying is to get Britain back on
the street and she's she's just saying
that you know I think he's actually said
one of the things in his commentary he
said that you know unlike the past four
taught me prime minister she's a
believer in in the power of free markets
and um Liberal
Liberal economic policies which deliver
growth and prosperity and that's what
she's aiming for so no she's not going
to please all the people all the time
and whatever the fracking proposals are
I think there's some there's some sense
that that that's going to happen that's
going to really hack off people beyond
the red War but you know what she's
saying is this is not she wants to
reboot the country she's almost to
reboot the city she wants to boost
construction she wants to get the
housing market going again she's
incentivizing investment she's got a
she's got a big list so I'm amazed that
she's hit the ground running in the way
she has I know Allison said she's had
more time I disagree with Carol here I
do think that she's she thinks is
popular but what she thinks is popular
with Hardline Tory voters she thinks is
popular with big business I don't think
she knows it's not going to be popular
with a lot of people because when I was
in big businesses
so she's doing what's up it has to be
satisfied to make this country work we
can't you know we can't yes she's like
and you said before that you know she's
got to look after the people who are
struggling well she is she's freezing
the the bill she's freezing that thing
at 2 500. that is a massive relief to
the poorestinals and there's there's
there's much more help as you well know
for the people for the real poor they're
getting much lower than they were
getting before so it's it's not fair to
say that she's not looking after the
president was also talked today of you
know even though the stamp duties you
made help the richest in society there
was talk of some kind of um you know
looking looking at council tax looking
to reform that for the poorest in the
country I mean yeah she's only been in
power for a couple of weeks you know
speak as well um the telegraph uh says
Mr Carter will announce two rabbits out
of the hat that have not previously been
reported which is maybe why they
announced National Insurance today
um but the paper also focuses on the
issue of inflation
um and and uh the chances of suggesting
is up to the bank to get a grip on
inflation
um should they have gone stronger today
do you think I've done uh 0.75 of a of a
basis point
whereas the banks are warning that some
of these policies are actually going to
increase inflation you know we've seen
this in the Tory leadership challenge
that what she's saying accents right
that a lot of these policies would in
the long term and you know end up in
increased inflation and it wasn't wise
just to go in and start cutting taxes
all around the place that that wasn't
the best way for growth I did think that
during that time that he seemed to be
more economically illiterate than Liz
trust that I accept that she has teams
of advisors around her and this is what
they've decided is the best policy
um I think that a lot of the the it's
clear from a lot of the reports that
will appear in tomorrow's papers that
the bank of England are quite nervous
about what is going to happen and
whether that is going to be enough to
try and turn the economy around
um and we gotta you know remember that
in the past when things like this have
been tried and they have laid what would
I saying that we're going to do a second
quarter
um of Decline and that's how you
identify our recession you know two
quarters won by your second right after
each other
um indicates and recession are we in a
recession yet I'm not sure that we're
quite there yet but we are heading that
way
before we reached that point that's what
we need to you need to wait and see
um Carol pick up with the metro and the
extraordinary pictures today of those uh
British men who'd been fighting in
Ukraine being freed as part of this big
as it turned out prisoner swab
yeah it's you Ukraine released um 55
Russian prince prisoners and one
Confidant of Putin who was Godfather to
one of his daughter's daughters and um
and Russia released what what zielinski
calls 215 Warriors his souls and five
Brits so uh this is great news these
guys the two guys are back home are
Aiden Islam and Sean Penner they're
they're back home tonight uh they had
been sentenced to death by the the
donest People's Republic and they were
fighting in Ukraine and were arrested by
troops there and and were sentences so
that it's fantastic news tonight that
they're back with their families one of
the most things that he was he's looking
forward to a a takeaway today but but
you know it's it's great news the deal
was broken by um Saudi Arabia and which
which got them free so it's um it's it's
fantastic news all right it's a bizarre
time to release them as well when all
this is going on it just you know when
Putin's kind of just threatened to Nuke
us yesterday and now um he's releasing
British prisoners but I mean thank God
he has yes and um The Daily Star and in
fact the telegraph is picking up on this
mobilization effort which clearly has
brought home to Russians how serious it
is although we are there's the the three
of the five britons uh released their
thumbs up from uh from one of them Mr
Harding there
um but yes the star has pictures of long
queues at airports certainly they've
queues uh on the way into Georgia as
well as families as I mentioned Alison
you know realized that actually this
mobilization could affect them
it is and you know what leads me to
believe that there are things going on
behind the scenes that maybe we don't
we're not fully aware of in terms of
what negotiations are going on we know
that Ukraine had made strides during the
week they had regained some territory
back the fact that these Prisoners the
pictures of them they look very thin
they look like they haven't had a great
time
um you would wonder would have come as a
warning to people who you know take
themselves off to Fighters mercenaries
and other countries without any real
understanding of of what the
consequences are and maybe these men
will come back and you know uh speak
some sense in terms of advising people
not to go after Ukraine without
realizing the consequences but what's
happening in Russia in terms of any
amount of fading age
um no being threatened that they could
be called up on this mobilization
they're fleeing but is that a tactic
used by Putin because he knows that he
needs some negotiations because we do
know that there are talks going on
behind the scenes I'm hopeful you know
that we could come to some sort of um
resolution not just because of the
ability and the death and the the misery
that's caused in that part of the world
but just it destabilizes the entire
world that's destabilized ourselves and
you would hope that we're coming near
the end game of this terrible War yes
well that that's the optimistic look at
it isn't it Alison Morris Cara Malone
thank you both very much indeed thank
you